D.C. SEWER SWAMP OPENING
MONOLOGUE.
THE ONE WE WILL GO THROUGH ALL
OF THIS VERY, VERY SLOWLY AND
PRECISELY, LOTS OF GROUND TO
COVER, WITH EVEN BREAKING NEWS
ON THE LAST 2 MINUTES.
TOMORROW MORNING WE WILL FINALLY
GET A CHANCE TO WITNESS ONE OF
THE MOST IMPORTANT HEARINGS IN
HISTORY OF SUPREME COURT
NOMINATIONS.
AS I'VE SAID MANY TIMES, THE
36-YEAR-OLD ALLEGATION SHOULD BE
TAKEN SERIOUSLY.
AND IT HAS BEEN BY REPUBLICANS
AND THE PRESIDENT.
AT 10:00 A.M. AND OPEN HEARINGS
THEY WILL LAY IT ALL ON THE
TABLE AND IN THE U.S. SENATE
THEY WILL MAKE AN INFORMED
DECISION ABOUT JUDGE KAVANAUGH.
REMEMBER, THEIR CONSTITUTIONAL
ROLE IS ADVICE AND CONSENT.
OF COURSE, THAT'S VERY
IMPORTANT.
40 YEARS OF ONE'S LIFE IS VERY
JUDGE KAVANAUGH HAS BEEN IN THE
PUBLIC SPOTLIGHT FOR ALL THESE
DECADES AND BECAUSE OF HIS WORK
HE IS LITERALLY FACED AND PASSED
SIX DEEP BACKGROUND FBI CHECKS.
THOSE THAT KNOW KAVANAUGH THE
BEST, I SCHOOL FRIENDS IN
COLLEGE FRIENDS, THOSE THAT WENT
TO LAW SCHOOL, GIRLFRIENDS,
COLLEAGUES, FELLOW JUDGES AND
CLERKS, THOSE PEOPLE THAT HAVE
ALL WORKED WITH HIM, WAS THE
COACH WITH BASKETBALL IN OTHER
SPORTS, DEMOCRATS AND
REPUBLICANS, I HAVE PRAISED
KAVANAUGH FOR HIS CHARACTER,
JUDGMENT AND FRIENDSHIP AND WHO
HE IS.
THROUGHOUT UNTIL 12 DAYS AGO,
ANY ALLEGATION OF ANY
SEXUAL MISCONDUCT EVER.
JUDGE KAVANAUGH HAS HAD ONE OF
THE MOST EXTENSIVE TRACK RECORDS
OF ANY FEDERAL JUDGE AND HE
WORKED ONE OF THE MOST HIGHEST
PROFILE FEDERAL COURTS.
HE'S BEEN THERE FOR YEARS AND WE
ALSO KNOW THAT PROFESSOR FORD
AND HER GROPING ALLEGATIONS
AGAINST HIM HAVE A LOT OF
ISSUES.
WE WILL GO STEP-BY-STEP THROUGH
EVERY ALLEGATION TONIGHT.
THESE CHARGES WERE MADE TO
CONGRESSIONAL DEMOCRATS, AND
WHILE JUST A FEW WEEKS AGO, NOT
AN INDEPENDENT LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCY.
BY THE WAY, THE CLAIM DATES BACK
TO WHEN FORD AND KAVANAUGH WERE
IN HIGH SCHOOL 36 YEARS AGO AND
FORD CANNOT REMEMBER A DATE OR
LOCATION OF THE ALLEGED
INCIDENT.
AND THE FOUR WITNESSES THAT FORD
LISTED TO CORROBORATE HER
CLAIMS, ALL OF THEM DENY WHAT
SHE IS ALLEGING AND PROFESSOR
FORD HAS REPRESENTED BY AN
ATTORNEY WHO POINTED OUT ON THIS
SHOW IS A LEFT-WING ACTIVIST WHO
ONCE VOWED TO RESIST
DONALD TRUMP AT EVERY LEVEL AND
HIS INCONSISTENT ON IMPORTANT
ISSUES INVOLVING
SEXUAL HARASSMENT IN THE
WORKPLACE.
SHE DIDN'T BELIEVE PAULA JONES
OBVIOUSLY, SHE DEFENDED
AL FRANKEN.
DESPITE ALL OF THESE WARNING
SIGNS, IT IS SO IMPORTANT THAT
PROFESSOR FORD AND JUDGE
KAVANAUGH SPEAK UNDER OATH.
THE PRESIDENT WOULD MAKE EVERY
ACCOMMODATION POSSIBLE AND
TONIGHT DEMOCRATS ARE DOING THE
EXACT OPPOSITE.
THEY HAVE ALREADY CONVICTED
JUDGE KAVANAUGH BEFORE EVEN
HEARING FROM HIM.
OR PROFESSOR FORD.
AND RUSHING TO JUDGMENT AGAINST
TWO UNCORROBORATED CLAIMS
AGAINST KAVANAUGH, ALLEGATIONS
THAT ARE SO SALACIOUS WILL
LITERALLY TONIGHT MAKE YOUR HEAD
SPIN.
THE SECOND PLANE THAT CAME OUT
IN THE NEW YORKER MAGAZINE WAS
SO OUTRAGEOUS AND SO
UNSUBSTANTIATED THAT EVEN THE
CHILD HATING "NEW YORK TIMES"
REFUSED TO OFFICIALLY REPORT ON
IT.
IN THIS CASE, A WOMAN NAMED
DEBORAH RAMIREZ.
SHE ALLEGES THAT IN THE 1980s,
KAVANAUGH MIGHT HAVE EXPOSED
HIMSELF TO HER AT A DRUNKEN
COLLEGE PARTY.
RAMIREZ HERSELF WASN'T TOTALLY
SURE IF IT WAS KAVANAUGH, IF HE
WAS THE PERPETRATOR.
ACCORDING TO HER OWN WORDS IN
HER OWN ACCOUNT SHE BECAME"
QUICKLY INEBRIATED" AT THE
PARTY.
SHE WAS "FOGGY AND SLURRING HER
WORDS" AND RAMIREZ EVEN
ACKNOWLEDGED THAT SHE HAD
SIGNIFICANT MEMORY GAPS FROM
THAT EVENING.
THOSE RAMIREZ LISTED IN HER CASE
TO THE INCIDENT HAVE ALL FLAT
FLATLY DENIED HER CHARGE
INCLUDING HER OWN BEST FRIENDS.
NOT A SINGLE PERSON CORROBORATE
HER STORY, NOT ONE.
MOMENTS AGO WE LEARNED THERE IS
ANOTHER ACCUSER MAKING AN
ANONYMOUS HEARSAY CLAIM ABOUT AN
INCIDENT THAT TOOK PLACE BETWEEN
KAVANAUGH AND A WOMAN IN 1998
AND THIS ANONYMOUS NBC NEWS
REPORT IS OBVIOUSLY A REPORT
THAT I DOUBT NBC NEWS WOULD EVER
MAKE ABOUT TOM BROKAW OR MATT
LAUER OR AND HE LACKED.
THEY WOULDN'T DO IT ABOUT PEOPLE
THAT THEY'VE WORKED WITH OR HAVE
WORKED WITH OVER THE YEARS.
SO THE QUESTION IS, I WAS JUDGE
KAVANAUGH SUPPOSED TO DEFEND
HIMSELF NOW FROM AN ANONYMOUS
ACCUSER AT THE 11TH HOUR?
WHICH NOW BRINGS US TO THE
SINGLE MOST SICKENING ALLEGATION
THAT THE LEFT WANTS YOU TO
BELIEVE AS ABSOLUTE FACT.
IT WAS BROUGHT INTO THE PUBLIC
DOMAIN BY -- YOU KNOW HIM, HE'S
ON FAKE NEWS CNN EVERY HOUR ON
THE HOUR AND IF HE IS NOT THERE
HE'S OVER ON CONSPIRACY TV AND
NBC.
MICHAEL AVENATTI, THE BOMBASTIC,
UNTRUSTWORTHY AND FAME SEEKING
ATTORNEY WHO MADE IT HIS LIFE'S
MISSION TO RESIST AND HATE
DONALD TRUMP, WHICH IS FINE.
HIS CLIENT IN THIS CASE IS A
WOMAN NAMED JULIE SWETNICK.
AT THIS LATE HOUR SHE IS
ALLEGING THAT BETWEEN 1981 AND
1983, SHE ATTENDED AT LEAST TEN
PARTIES, WHERE SHE CLAIMS THAT
JUDGE KAVANAUGH AND HIS FRIEND
MARK JUDGE ROUTINELY DRUG TO
FEMALE PARTYGOERS.
THIS HAPPENED REGULARLY, ALMOST
ON A WEEKEND BASIS.
AND EVEN IN THE SUMMER.
AND IT WAS AN ORGANIZED SCHEME
TO EITHER GIVE THEM GRAIN
ALCOHOL OR DRUGS, TO GANG OR
TRAIN RAPED THESE VICTIMS.
SHE ALSO CLAIMS TO HAVE BEEN
PART OF ONE OF THOSE GANG RAPES.
SHE'S SAYING THAT THEY WOULD
ATTEND PARTIES AND YOUNG GIRLS
WERE DRUGGED AND.
NOR DID ANYONE ELSE THAT EVER
WENT TO ANY OF THESE PARTIES,
NOT A SINGLE PARTY.
NO SPECIFIC DATES WERE GIVEN AND
NO NAMES WERE GIVEN OTHER THAN
MARK JUDGE AND JUDGE KAVANAUGH.
NO OTHER WITNESSES LISTED, NO
ONE HAS CORROBORATED THESE
CLAIMS.
DURING THE ALLEGED TIME PERIOD,
SHE WOULD HAVE BEEN ENROLLED IN
COLLEGE WHILE KAVANAUGH WOULD
HAVE BEEN A 15 OR 16-YEAR-OLD
HIGH SCHOOL STUDENT.
SHE DESCRIBED BOYS WAITING IN
LINE TO RAPE DRUGGED WOMEN.
SHE SAID SHE WENT TO AT LEAST
TEN OF THESE PARTIES AND MANY
MORE HAPPENED AND NOBODY EVER
TOLD THE TEACHER.
A LAW ENFORCEMENT
REPRESENTATIVE, APPEARANCE,
ANYBODY, EVERYONE THAT WAS A
PART OF THIS ALL KEPT IT SECRET.
IN A STATEMENT, KAVANAUGH
REACTED TO THIS AND THIS IS WHAT
HE SAID.
THIS IS RIDICULOUS AND FROM THE
TWILIGHT ZONE.
I DON'T KNOW WHO THIS IS IN THIS
NEVER HAPPENED.
TODAY, JUST HOURS AFTER THESE
ALLEGATIONS BECAME PUBLIC, 64
HIGH SCHOOL ACQUAINTANCES AND
FRIENDS OF JUDGE KAVANAUGH
RUSHED TO HIS DEFENSE IN A
STATEMENT, CALLING THESE CLAIMS
"NONSENSE.
WE NEVER WITNESSED ANY BEHAVIOR
THAT EVEN APPROACH IS WHAT IS
DESCRIBED IN THIS ALLEGATION.
IT IS REPREHENSIBLE AND THE
EXTENSIVE AMOUNT OF TIME WE HAVE
COLLECTIVELY SPENT WITH BRETT
KAVANAUGH, WE DO NOT RECALL
HAVING EVER MET SOMEONE NAMED
JULIE SWETNICK, NOR DID WE EVER
OBSERVE HIM ENGAGING IN ANY
CONDUCT RESEMBLING THAT
DESCRIBED IN HER SO-CALLED
DECLARATION.
REMEMBER, JUDGE KAVANAUGH TOLD
OUR OWN MARTHA MacCALLUM THAT
HE WAS A THROUGHOUT ALL OF
HIGH SCHOOL AND MOST OF COLLEGE.
CAN'T BELIEVE WE ARE DISCUSSING
THIS, BUT WE ARE, IS WHAT HE
SAID.
>> PEOPLE GENERALLY IN
HIGH SCHOOL, I THINK ALL OF US
HAVE DONE THINGS IN HIGH SCHOOL
THAT WE LOOK BACK ON AND REGRET
OR CRINGE A BIT.
THAT'S NOT WHAT WE ARE TALKING
ABOUT, WE ARE TALKING ABOUT AN
ALLEGATION OF SEXUAL ASSAULT.
I NEVER SEXUALLY ASSAULTED
ANYONE, I NEVER HAD ANY
INTERCOURSE OR ANYTHING CLOSE TO
INTERCOURSE IN HIGH SCHOOL AND
MANY YEARS THEREAFTER.
THE GIRLS FROM THE SCHOOLS I
WENT TO AND I WERE FINE.
>> SO YOU ARE SAYING THAT
THEY'RE ALL THESE YEARS IN
QUESTION YOU ARE A?
>> THAT'S CORRECT.
>> IF YOU NEVER HAD INTERCOURSE
WITH ANYONE HIGH SCHOOL AND
THROUGH COLLEGE SINCE WE ARE
PROBING INTO YOUR PERSONAL LIFE
HERE?
>> MANY YEARS AFTER, I WILL
LEAVE IT AT THAT.
>> Sean: NOW TODAY
SENATOR LINDSEY GRAHAM TWEETED
OUT "I HAVE A DIFFICULT TIME
BELIEVING THAT ANY PERSON COULD
CONTINUE GOING TO TEN PARTIES
OVER A TWO-YEAR PERIOD WHERE
WOMEN WERE ROUTINELY GANG RAPE
ED AND NOT REPORTED.
WHY WOULD ANY PERSON CAN NEED TO
PUT THEMSELVES AND THEIR FRIENDS
IN DANGER?
ISN'T THERE SOME DUTY TO WARN
OTHERS?
AND ALSO BREAKING MOMENTS BEFORE
WE CAME ON AIR, NEW REPORTS THAT
A RESTRAINING ORDER WAS FILED
AGAINST JULIE SWETNICK BY HER
EX-BOYFRIEND IN 2001.
HER BOYFRIEND TONIGHT TELLING
THE POLITICO "RIGHT AFTER I
BROKE UP WITH HER SHE WAS
THREATENING MY FAMILY, MY WIFE,
THREATENING TO DO HARM TO MY
BABY AT THAT TIME.
AND THEN SHE SAID IN A TELEPHONE
CONVERSATION WITH POLITICO, I
KNOW A LOT ABOUT HER, SHE'S NOT
CREDIBLE AT ALL, HE SAID IT, NOT
AT ALL.
LOOK WITH
"THE WALL STREET JOURNAL" IS
REPORTING JUST MINUTES AGO.
ROUGHLY A DECADE AGO, JULIE
SWETNICK WAS INVOLVED IN A
DISPUTE WITH A FORMER EMPLOYER,
EMPLOYER, NEW YORK LIFE
INSURANCE COMPANY, OVER A
SEXUAL HARASSMENT COMPLAINT THAT
SHE FILED.
ACCORDING TO PEOPLE FAMILIAR
WITH HER, THE FIRM WAS RUN BY
DEBORAH KATZ, THE LAWYER
CURRENTLY REPRESENTING DR. FORD
AND THE COMPANY FINALLY REACHED
A SETTLEMENT WITH JULIE SWETNICK
ACCORDING TO PEOPLE IN
"THE WALL STREET JOURNAL" ."
DESPITE EVERYTHING WE HAVE NOW
SHOW DEAL, YOU HAVE, AND THIS IS
WHY WE ARE IN A CRISIS IN THIS
COUNTRY.
MANY IN THE LEFT, MANY IN THE
MEDIA, THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY,
THEY HAVE ALREADY CONVICTED
JUDGE KAVANAUGH OF WHAT A
HORRIFIC, LIFE SHATTERING CLAIM
AND WE HAVE THE EVIDENCE, TAKE A
LOOK.
>> THIS IS A MONUMENTAL,
DEFINING MOMENT THIS WEEK.
WHEN YOU HAVE SOMEONE LIKE
COFFEE GOING TO PRISON AND THEN
KAVANAUGH GOING TO THE HIGHEST
COURT IN THE LAND.
>> TO BE HONEST THAT'S A VERY
WHITE MALE DEFENSE.
>> PART OF THIS BACKLASH THAT WE
ARE SEEING RIGHT NOW COMES FROM
A CULTURE OF SEXISM AND
PATERNALISM IN THIS COUNTRY, AND
THAT SILENCE GENERATION AFTER
GENERATION.
>> THIS IS A PATRIARCHAL ON FOR
MY FULL DISPLAY.
>> THAT TO ME -- IT JUST WAS NOT
BELIEVABLE.
>> WE ALLOW THE PREDATOR IN
CHIEF, THE ADMITTED PREDATOR IN
CHIEF TO PLACE PEOPLE ON THE
SUPREME COURT.
HE IS PICKING THE TYPE OF PEOPLE
THAT ARE ESSENTIALLY LIKE HIM.
AND THIS THING AS A WHOLE
INVESTIGATION NOW, IT SHOULD NOT
GO FORWARD.
>> Sean: WHILE THE LEFT, THE
MEDIA AND THE DEMOCRATS ALL RUSH
TO JUDGMENT, MANY OTHERS WITH
SERIOUS CRIMINAL CLAIMS WILL
UTILIZE THE SERVICES OF THE
POLITICAL, VERY ANTI-TRUMPET,
AND IT'S A SLEAZY LAWYER NAMED
MICHAEL AVENATTI.
EARLIER TODAY THE PRESIDENT HAD
THIS TO SAY ABOUT HIM, TAKE A
LOOK.
>> President Trump: IF YOU
TAKE A LOOK AT THIS LAWYER THAT
JUST CAME OUT, HE'S A LOWLIFE.
HE REPRESENTED DEMOCRATS AND
NOBODY EVER TALKS ABOUT THAT.
IT'S NOT A VERY GOOD ONE BUT HE
IS A DEMOCRATIC LAWYER SO IT'S A
HORRIBLE CON GAME AND I THINK
THE PEOPLE ARE FINDING IT OUT.
>> Sean: I WANT EVERYONE TO
THINK ABOUT THIS BECAUSE I
BELIEVE AMERICANS ARE
FAIR-MINDED.
THIS ISN'T ABOUT REPUBLICANS OR
DEMOCRATS DENIED ALL OR
CONSERVATIVE OR LIBERAL.
MICHAEL AVENATTI, NANCY PELOSI,
MAXINE WATERS, NOW THE NEW FACES
OF THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
WE HAVE AN ELECTION IN 41 DAYS.
I CALL MENOTTI GEARING UP FOR A
PRESIDENTIAL RUN.
THIS IS NOW, AND THIS IS WHAT WE
GOT TO THINK ABOUT.
THIS IS NOW A PARTY OF NO DUE
PROCESS, NO RULE OF LAW, NO
CONSTITUTION, A ZERO PRESUMPTION
OF INNOCENCE.
DO YOU KNOW, IT'S IN THE LAST 12
DAYS I CAN'T FIND A SINGLE
DEMOCRAT THAT IS WILLING TO
DEFEND THE PRINCIPAL OF
PRESUMPTION OF INNOCENCE AND DUE
PROCESS?
BY THE WAY, THE PARTY OF
BILL CLINTON AND KEITH ELLISON.
SO TONIGHT WHAT WE ARE SEEING
FROM MICHAEL AVENATTI ON THE
PEOPLE ON THE LEFT IN THIS
COUNTRY, SADLY, I TELL YOU THIS
ALL THE TIME.
THEY USE THIS TACTIC EVERY TWO
AND FOUR YEARS, CHARACTER
ASSASSINATION.
IT'S THE NUMBER ONE TOOL IN THE
DEMOCRATIC PLAYBOOK AND
SOMETHING THE PRESIDENT CALLED
OUT EARLY TODAY AND A POWERFUL
PRESS CONFERENCE.
HOW OFTEN DO I SAY EVERY TWO OR
FOUR YEARS, THEY WILL CALL
REPUBLICANS RACIST?
HOW HORRIBLE IS THAT, SEXIST AND
MISOGYNIST, XENA PHOBIC AND
HOMOPHOBIC, ISLAMOPHOBIC?
REPUBLICANS WANT DIRTY AIR AND
WATER AND THEY WANT CHILDREN TO
DIE AND THEY WANT TO THROW
GRANNY OVER THE CLIFF.
WE'VE NOW GOTTEN USED TO IT.
BUT TO SAY THAT ABOUT PEOPLE,
EVERY ELECTION SEASON, TO DO
THIS WITH EVERY SUPREME COURT
NOMINEE, HERE'S WHAT THE
PRESIDENT SAID.
>> President Trump: THEY ARE
ACTUALLY CON ARTISTS BECAUSE
THEY KNOW WHAT QUALITY THIS MAN
IS AND THEY'VE DESTROYED A MAN'S
REPUTATION AND THEY WANT TO
DESTROY IT EVEN MORE.
I THINK PEOPLE WILL SEE THAT IN
THE MIDTERMS, BUT THEY HAVE DONE
TO THIS FAMILY AND WHAT THEY
HAVE DONE TO THESE CHILDREN,
THESE BEAUTIFUL CHILDREN OF HIS
AND WHAT THEY HAVE DONE TO HIS
WIFE.
AND THEY KNOW IT IS A BIG FAT
CON JOB.
THEY GO INTO A ROOM AND I
GUARANTEE YOU, THEY LAUGH LIKE
HELL AT WHAT THEY HAVE PULLED
OFF ON YOU AND ON THE PUBLIC.
THEY LAUGH LIKE HELL.
>> Sean: THE PRESIDENT KNOWS
THE SHAMEFUL TACTICS OF THE LEFT
FIRSTHAND.
REMEMBER DURING THE PRESIDENTIAL
ELECTION, REMEMBER WHEN
"THE NEW YORK TIMES," I THINK IT
WAS TOP FOLD, THEY FALSELY
ACCUSE PRESIDENT TRUMP
SEXUAL MISCONDUCT, THE SO-CALLED
BOMBSHELL STORY.
THE ONLY PROBLEM IS THE SOURCE
OF THE TIME USED DENIED TRUMP
EVER ACTED INAPPROPRIATELY.
WE KNOW BECAUSE WE INTERVIEWED
SOME OF THEM, A NUMBER OF THEM.
HERE'S WHAT THE PRESIDENT SAID
ABOUT THAT EARLIER TODAY.
>> President Trump: I WAS
ACCUSED BY, I BELIEVE IT WAS FOR
WOMEN.
YOU CAN CHECK WITH SEAN HANNITY
OR FOX BECAUSE THEY COVERED IT
VERY STRONGLY.
I WAS ACCUSED BY FOUR OR FIVE
WOMEN WHO GOT PAID A LOT OF
MONEY TO MAKE UP STORIES ABOUT
ME.
WE CAUGHT THEM IN THE MAINSTREAM
MEDIA REFUSED TO PUT THAT ON
TELEVISION.
THEY REFUSE TO EVEN WRITE ABOUT
IT.
>> Sean: WE ACTUALLY FOLLOWED
UP ON THAT PROGRAM.
EVERYONE ELSE IN THE MEDIA
IGNORING AND GOING ALONG WITH
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" AND WHAT
THEY PUT OUT.
I ACTUALLY DID SOME REPORTING
AND HAD THE OPPORTUNITY TO
INTERVIEW THE WOMEN FROM THE AT
TIMES FAKE NEWS STORY.
HERE'S WHAT THEY SAID AFTER THE
TIMES MAKE THE ACCUSATION.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> I'VE NEVER SEEN HIM BE
ANYTHING BUT A GENTLEMAN, A VERY
GRACIOUS TO WOMEN AND RESPECTFUL
OF WOMEN.
ANYBODY THAT TELLS ME THAT I SAW
THAT IT IS.
HE WASN'T THAT WAY TO ME OR
ANYBODY.
I MET A LOT OF WOMEN WHEN HE WAS
AROUND.
HE EMPLOYS A LOT OF WOMEN AT
DEALS WITH A LOT OF WOMEN AND HE
RESPECTS THEM AND THEY RESPECT
HIM.
>> I BASICALLY WOULDN'T GIVE
THEM A STORY AND THEN THEY CAME
OUT WITH THEIR OWN VERSION OF IT
AND TOOK SOMETHING OUT OF MY
BOOK AND TOTALLY TWISTED IT AND
MADE IT SO NEGATIVE.
I HAVE NOTHING BUT POSITIVE
THINGS TO SAY ABOUT DONALD TRUM
DONALD TRUMP.
>> Sean: I DON'T REMEMBER THE
RETRACTION IN
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" EITHER.
THE LEFT'S CHARACTER
ASSASSINATION STRATEGY DIDN'T
START WITH PRESIDENT TRUMP, IT'S
A TIME-TESTED PRACTICE FROM THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
REMEMBER WHAT THEY DID TO
SUPREME COURT, ROBERT        ROB
SUPREME COURT, ROBERT        ROR
SUPREME COURT, ROBERT        ROT
SUPREME COURT, ROBERT        ROB
SUPREME COURT, ROBERT        ROR
REAGAN'S NOMINEE FOR THE U.S.
SUPREME COURT, ROBERT        RO?
HE WAS NEVER NOMINATED BECAUSE
OF ALL THE SLANDER.
THE GUY THAT TOLD NOBODY AFTER
HE LEFT A WOMAN TO DIE AFTER A
CAR ACCIDENT AND WENT HOME AND
WENT TO BED?
ROBERT CHAPPAQUIDDICK KENNEDY.
>> THIS IS A LAND WHERE WOMEN
WILL BE FORCED INTO BACK ALLEY
ABORTIONS, BLACK WOULD SIT AT
SEGREGATED LUNCH COUNTERS, ROGUE
POLICE COULD BREAK DOWN CITIZEN
STORES IN MIDNIGHT RAIDS AND
WRITERS AND ARTISTS WOULD BE
CENSURED AT THE WHIM OF
GOVERNMENT.
>> Sean: THEN A FEW YEARS
LATER, OF COURSE DEMOCRATS TRIED
TO BRING THE PRIME COURT JUSTICE
WHO BECAME ONE OF THE FINEST
JUSTICES IN OUR GENERATION,
CLARENCE THOMAS, THROUGH THE
MUD.
1991, SENATE DEMOCRATS PULLED
OUT HIS FORMER COLLEAGUE ANITA
HILL MAKING SEXUAL HARASSMENT
ALLEGATIONS AGAINST HIM.
SOUND FAMILIAR?
THIS CHARACTER ASSASSINATION WAS
SO VICIOUS AND SO HORRIBLE, SO
NASTY, JUSTICE THOMAS CALLED IT
A HIGH-TECH LYNCHING.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> THIS IS A CIRCUS, IT'S A
NATIONAL DISGRACE.
AND FROM MY STANDPOINT AS A
BLACK AMERICAN, AS FAR AS I'M
CONCERNED, IT IS A HIGH-TECH
LYNCHING FOR UPPITY BLACKS WHO
IN ANY WAY DEIGNED TO THINK FOR
THEMSELVES.
TO DO FOR THEMSELVES.
TO HAVE DIFFERENT IDEAS.
AND IT IS A MESSAGE THAT UNLESS
YOU KOWTOW TO AN OLD ORDER, THIS
IS WHAT WILL HAPPEN TO YOU.
YOU WILL BE LYNCHED, DESTROYED,
CARICATURED BY A COMMITTEE OF
THE U.S. SENATE, RATHER THAN
HUNG FROM A TREE.
>> Sean: THE CIRCUS OF
DISGRACE IS BACK IN WASHINGTON
AND THESE TACTICS DON'T STOP AT
THE SUPREME COURT NOMINEES, MANY
ALSO TRY TO DESTROY THE
CHARACTER.
I KNOW, I WAS IN ATLANTA AT THE
TIME OF THE OLYMPIC BOMBING.
RICHARD JEWELL FALSELY ACCUSED
AS BEING THE LONE BOMBER.
HE FIT THE PROFILE BECAUSE HE
LIVED WITH HIS MOTHER.
HE WAS LISTENING TO MY RADIO
SHOW AT THE TIME AND SAID I WAS
THE ONLY ONE THAT STOOD UP FOR
HIM AT LEAST GAVE HIM THE
PRESUMPTION OF INNOCENCE.
HE CHANGED MY LIFE.
THEY ALSO SMEARED FALSELY
ACCUSED -- REMEMBER THE DUKE
LACROSSE TEAM?
WE DIDN'T RUSH TO JUDGMENT ON
THE SHOW.
AND LET'S NOT FORGET WITH THE
LEFT DATED IN FERGUSON.
DARREN WILSON WAS FOUND INNOCENT
IN THAT CASE.
REMEMBER BALTIMORE, FREDDIE
GRAY?
TRAVE ON MARTIN, GEORGE
ZIMMERMAN.
HOW MANY TIMES DID
PRESIDENT OBAMA RUSH TO
JUDGMENT?
THE CAMBRIDGE POLICE ACTED
STUPIDLY.
DURING EVERY BIG MOMENT, SO MANY
IN THE LEFT AND SO MANY IN THE
PRESS RUSHED TO JUDGMENT FOR
PURE POLITICAL GAIN.
THERE IS NO PRESUMPTION OF
INNOCENCE EVER WITH THESE PEOPLE
WHEN IT COMES TO POLITICS.
HARRY REID LIES ABOUT
MITT ROMNEY AND SAID HE HASN'T
PAID TAXES IN TEN YEARS.
WHEN ASKED ABOUT IT LATER AFTER
THE ELECTION AND ROMNEY LOST, HE
BOASTS ABOUT EIGHT.
HE'S PROUD OF HIS LIFE.
THIS HAPPENS EVERY ELECTION
SEASON, ONE OF THE BIGGEST
SMEARED JOBS OF ALL COMES FROM
CHRISTOPHER STEELE'S DIRTY
DOSSIER.
A DOCUMENT BOUGHT AND PAID FOR
BY HILLARY CLINTON AND THE DNC
TO LIE TO YOU, THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE, TO REAGAN ELECTION IN
THIS COUNTRY AND THEN TO DESTROY
A PRESIDENT AFTER WITH ABSURD
UNTRUE SALACIOUS CLAIMS LIKE
THIS.
TRUMPS A "PERVERTED CONDUCT IN
MOSCOW INCLUDED PAIRING THE
PRESIDENTIAL SUITE AT THE HOTEL
WHERE HE KNEW PRESIDENT OBAMA
HAD STAYED ON ONE OF THE TRIPS
TO RUSSIA AND DEFILING THE BED
WHERE THEY HAD SLEPT BY HIRING A
NUMBER OF TO PERFORM GOLDEN
SHOWERS, IN OTHER WORDS, IN
FRONT OF HIM.
HE SAID THAT DOSSIER, THERE IS
ONLY A 50/50 CHANCE.
THOSE LIES WERE SPREAD TO YOU OF
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
HILLARY PAID FOR IT, RUSSIAN
ALLIES OF ALL THINGS.
YET THE LEFT PUSH THESE
UNVERIFIED AND UNCORROBORATED
CLAIMS THROUGHOUT THE HIGHEST
LEVELS OF OUR GOVERNMENT RIGHT
INTO THE GULLIBLE MEDIA, THEIR
ARM THAT PUSHES THEIR
PROPAGANDA.
AS YOU CAN SEE, THE LEFT'S
ATTEMPT TO DESTROY THE LIVES OF
PEOPLE WITH BASELESS CLAIMS, IT
IS A CLEAR, OBVIOUS AND NOW
PREDICTABLE PATTERN.
THESE ARE REAL PEOPLE
UNFORTUNATELY, THESE ARE REAL
LIVES WHEN YOU SAY THAT SOMEONE
IS A RACIST OR SEXIST OR
HOMOPHOBE, A GANG, REAL
FAMILIES.
DEMOCRATS, USING ALL OF THEM.
PAWNS IN A POLITICAL GAIN, NO
DUE PROCESS AND NO PERCEPTION OF
INNOCENCE.
HOW WOULD YOU FEEL IF IT WAS
YOU, AMERICA COMES TONIGHT?
BECAUSE THIS IS THE MODERN
DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
THEY HAVE NOW DEFINED OF
THEMSELVES AS A PARTY OF
SLANDERERS, SMEAR, CHARACTER
ASSASSINATION AND A PARTY OF
THIS PARCHMENT.
THIS IS CLEARLY WHO THEY ARE
BECAUSE I CAN'T FIND A DEMOCRAT
NOW SAYING THEY BELIEVE IN THE
PRESUMPTION OF INNOCENCE.
THIS NOW DEFINES THEM.
THE ONLY ONE POWER FOR
THEMSELVES.
ARE THEY TALKING ABOUT THE
ECONOMY, ABOUT SECURITY FOR THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE?
THIS IS WHY EVERY FAIR-MINDED
AMERICAN HAS A RIGHT TO BE
SKEPTICAL TONIGHT.
WHAT YOU ARE WITNESSING IS ONE
OF THE UGLIEST SMEAR CAMPAIGNS
IN HISTORY.
IF AMERICA DOESN'T GET THIS
RIGHT, THERE WILL BE NO GOOD
PEOPLE IN THIS COUNTRY THAT EVER
WANT TO SERVE THEIR COUNTRY FOR
DECADES TO COME.
WHY WOULD THEY?
THEY ARE NOT DOING IT FOR THE
MONEY.
DEMOCRATS ARE NOW THE PARTY OF
NO DUE PROCESS.
THEY ARE THE PARTY OF NO
PRESUMPTION OF INNOCENCE.
THEY ARE NOT THE PARTY THAT
BELIEVES IN THE CONSTITUTION.
AS ONE DEMOCRAT SAID,
PRESUMPTION OF INNOCENCE?
I HAVEN'T HEARD THEM.
AND YOU WANT TO KNOW WHY?
BECAUSE THEY ALL SEEM TO BELIEVE